♪ Bride, bride, bibbity bride ♪
♪ I'm gonna wed this bride ♪
♪ Tonight ♪
♪ Bride, bride, bibbity bride ♪
♪ I'm gonna wed this bride ♪
♪ Tonight, yeah ♪
And now by the power
invested in me
as Moonbeam City
Chief of Police,
I pronounce you
husband and wife.
You must kiss the bride.
[gulps]
Okay.
Let's make a kiss, then.
[smooches]
Uh--ne--mm.
(Rad)
Uhh.
Oh, come on, Rad.
Kiss your bride.
Come on,
kiss her.
None of us can leave
until you kiss her.
- Mm...
- Kiss her.
(all)
Kiss her, kiss her, kiss her...
What's wrong with you, man?
Kiss your sister.
Stop!
This wedding is a sham.
[all gasping]
Talc is Rad's sister.
Ugh!
[crashes]
What?
Why didn't you tell me
you were my sister, Talc?
I rescind my song.
Do not wed this bride bride
bibbity bride.
Wait, the lies
don't stop there.
(man)
They don't?
[all gasping]
Last night, Quench said
Rad had just one big toe.
Well, I looked up all recorded
cases of Canadian monotoe-ism,
and I have found only two:
actor Zinc Moranis,
and this boy.
Who's that?
(Chrysalis)
He was the only son
of the Mannings,
the billionaire founders of
Flamingo Computers.
Despite his freakish foot,
the Mannings loved him.
He had everything he could have
wanted--a play room
full of toys, a miniwave tech
child's yacht.
Until one day,
he was kidnapped.
[all gasping]
(Chrysalis)
That was you, Rad.
You're Gregory Manning.
(Chrysalis)
These people stole you,
and now they're trying
to rip us all off!
I'm Gregory Manning?
You lied to me?
I should have been really rich
and happy all along?
Aw, cram it,
you cry baby.
God damn it,
you red-headed bitch!
You ruined my daughter's
wedding!
Time to catch the lead bouquet!
Blam-o!
Ow!
Mom!
Jesus, Rad's mom
just shot Chrysalis.
Talc, keep those cops
on the ground.
Your pop and I
are gonna grab the gifts.
Quench, stuff the cash
in the toaster!
[gunfire]
Aah!
Chrysalis, are you okay?
Yep--yeah, she only
got my shoulder.
Now go--go stop
your parents.
[gunfire]
Oh, no, she's got a gun!
You're police officers.
You all have guns!
Right.
[gunfire]
That's it.
Time to wake the snake.
[heroic techno music]
Ow, you whipped my eye out,
you bitch.
[gunshot]
[glass breaking]
The cops broke the cease fire.
God damn it.
I knew this would happen!
[gunfire]
[glass breaking]
They're revolving away.
Should we keep shooting?
No, we got to wait for it
to go around again.
[clock ticking]
Okay, here they come--let's go,
let's go, let's go, let's go!
[gunfire]
[techno music]
[clock ticking]
[gunfire]
♪ ♪
[clock ticking]
[gunfire]
Oh, this is driving me crazy.
Let's just go over there!
[dings]
[shouting]
[gunfire]
Whoa.
If it isn't the cop
who killed my dad
and [bleep] my sister.
[gunfire]
- Aah!
[car horn honks]
[laughs]
I'm gonna shoot your little
pig fingers off one by one.
[gunshots]
- Losing...
my...grisp.
Dazzle, play along with me.
Boogie Woogie.
Eight to the bar.
One, two, three, four!
[upbeat piano music]
[gunshots]
Ugh!
[gunshots and piano music]
The boogie woogie make
his fingers move too fast.
[gunshots and piano music]
Oh!
Ha!
Whoo!
Yeah!
- Hey, Neongelo.
- What?
Eat snake belt.
Whoa!
Ow!
You shot me in the shoulder!